ladies and gentlemen please welcome the
second president of the Confederate
States of America
[Applause]
thank you thank you I'm gonna get mean
and divisive in a few minutes but first
I want to take a moment to acknowledge
the tragic victim of the events in
Charlottesville me you are not the
victim of Charlottesville you barely
even denounced the hate group excuse me
excuse me let me finish because I am now
going to denounce the worst hate group
of them all the press I hate you so
you're a hate group with your stupid
glasses okay you're calling the press a
hate group when you side with white
supremacist I don't side with white
supremacist honey I don't see color I
can't because on Monday I stared
directly into this whole Afghanistan
question go excuse me excuse me there
they go they're turning the cameras off
because they don't want you to see this
no we're not the cameras are on there no
no no look at me whatever camera you're
watching me on right now has been turned
off why can't you just tell people the
truth don't question me you people need
to be civil that's why tonight's theme
is civility we need to return to the
genteel ways of our southern whatever
who cares you know I don't care this is
ridiculous here's what I mean I'm only
talking to white people and if you think
about it that way I kind of make sense
battling but please let's keep our war
civil a civil war I'm the president can
you succeed it what's wrong